The Duality between syntax and semantics
a generalization of stone
Duality well all these dualities are
related you know they're there there are
all kinds of dualities out there you
know where Duality the the the idea of
Duality originally comes from right two
points determine a line two lines
determine a point where the lines
intersect you've got a point you know
whereas if you draw two points put two
points on a piece of paper you can draw
a line between that's a duality
basically you permute your uh your terms
uh and you still have an invariant truth
what the original form of the relation
remains true so that's that's what a
duality is anytime you can do that
anytime there is an invariant and you
can switch things around within that
invariant and the invariant stays true
that's a duality there are many kinds of
Duality at the CTV